this is some of the stock that we've got
for the chinese market
mitchell taylor's winery has been
selling australian wine since the 1960s
it retails for approximately a thousand
dollars a bottle
and in the past five years china has
been his main focus
that's the back label there with all the
chinese details
but these bottles can now be three times
as expensive because china has imposed
new tariffs of up to 212 percent on
australian wine
i was absolutely shocked it really did
hit me hard
since may australia has been caught in a
trade dispute with china
it has hit not just the wine industry
but also coal barley
lobster and beef some economists say as
much as six percent of australia's gdp
hangs in the balance it's an attack on
free countries
everywhere the bilateral trade dispute
has gone global
china hawks and lawmakers from across
the political spectrum and around the
world
are taking australia aside the white
house national security council even
tweeted that it would serve australian
wine at its holiday reception
politicians are jumping on china's wine
tariff to draw global attention to what
they see as beijing's bullying and
australia's wine makers hope this new
coalition can help save their industry
it's a great initiative the coalition of
partners
can come together and help us all put
pressure
on the chinese regime
the virus began in china and wuhan
that's i think well understood
this statement is what sparked the
dispute when back in april the
australian government called for an
investigation into the origin of the
coronavirus pandemic
beijing which has suggested that the
virus came from outside china
dispelled the criticism
but this diplomatic tussle is about more
than the virus
china has pointed out several grievances
against australia
like when it banned chinese telecom firm
huawei from its 5g network
because it said it posed a national
security threat even though huawei said
it has operated safely in the country
[Applause]
and when australia condemned china's
controversial national security law in
hong kong
which beijing said is a domestic matter
so in may
china slapped tariffs of up to 80 on
barley followed by levies on other goods
timber exports were also stopped at
chinese customs
for entrepreneurs like mitchell taylor
these tensions threaten their businesses
as they've been big on china and
invested to expand production by buying
new land
and upgrading facilities our current
sales into the chinese market
are about 10 to 15 percent we've been
explaining
our wines and matching them with the
very good
chinese cuisine taylor says sales in
china have doubled over the past four
years
as drinking wine became a status symbol
for the chinese middle class
to appeal to more chinese drinkers
taylor adapted his products
the chinese customers they're fascinated
with
technology we have a microchip here
it is a great security seal
taylor also uses gold on labels which is
perceived as a lucky color in china
he created heavy wooden boxes that he
said chinese customers associate with
exclusivity
and the company even produced wines that
taylor says chinese consumers like to
have with hotpot
taylor's isn't the only winery in
australia to have bet big on china
exports there have tripled in the past
five years to hit 907 million dollars in
2019.
australia's economy as a whole has come
to rely on china
sending a third of its exports to the
mainland
australia has not had an economic
recession
in about two decades and
much of that is thanks to china's rise
viki shu is an analyst who's been
studying australia's increasingly tense
relationship with china
despite the closer economic relationship
between both countries
australia's government has been raising
its voice on political issues sensitive
to beijing
people in the business community are
very anxious here in australia
the current administration is speaking
out assertively on issues like human
rights
but the question is can we really stand
up for our values despite
economic losses we will not be bullied
this trade dispute especially china's
wine tariff has caught the attention of
a new alliance of more than a hundred
lawmakers for more than a dozen
countries
they say trade policies shouldn't be
used as a political tool
we are asking you all to join us in
standing against ching yangping's
authoritarian bullying
by drinking a bottle or two of
australian wine
as trade disputes multiply in a
globalized economy
viki shu says countries that share
political values could increasingly rely
on each other's market
everyone knows they will have help and
they will have backup
when they're also being punished by
beijing for perceived
indiscretion we really do appreciate our
allies and friends coming together
we've got an opportunity now to
re-launch in
the u.s market the uk and in canada
but because consumers there are
different from the chinese taylor
is tweaking the marketing around his
lineup of more than 50 bottles
the labels in chinese we'll have to rip
them off
we'll have to rebottle it and then
repackage it
for the u.s market taylor is using
floral labels to appeal to young urban
consumers
and will start exporting vegan wine to
cities like new york and los
angeles and for the long term
he's planting more shiraz and grenache
which are growing in popularity in the
west
still it'll be difficult to make up for
lost business
some australia-based foreign policy
analysts hope with the incoming biden
administration
like-minded countries could work
together to confront china
as the president-elect has said that he
will seek to strengthen global alliances
the idea that we're going to be able to
deal with china's rogue behavior when we
make up
25 of the world's economy without
bringing in the other 40 percent of our
allies
is not realistic meanwhile china says
it's committed to free trade and that
its tariff measures
are in line with international customary
practices and that it's now up to
australia to repair the relationship
taylor knows he's closing out a tough
2020 without the same access to the
china market
but he says he's learned a lesson for
next year this whole
incident has really taught us
not to get too focused on one customers
we've just got to diversify and do that